Hello. This
is 6 Minute
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Beth.
And I'm Neil.
If you really love something,
maybe a sport or a hobby,
a music band or a TV show,
you might call yourself a fan.
Nowadays, thanks to the internet, fans
from around the world can meet online
to share their passion
and this has led to a new word, fandom.
Fandom is more than simply being a fan.
It's a whole culture created by
a community of people
to share their love
of the same thing.
What's more, fandom has started
to develop its own language.
In this programme, we'll be taking a trip
into the world of fandoms and, as usual,
we will be learning some new
and useful vocabulary, too.
But before that I have a question
for you, Neil.
The original word 'fan' was first used
about Americans
in the early 20th century.
But what were
these Americans fans of?
Was it: a) Hollywood movie stars,
b) baseball or c) Disney cartoons.
I'll guess they were fans
of Disney cartoons.
OK, Neil. We'll find out later
in the programme.
Michael Bond is the author
of a new book, Fans.
Here he discusses the meaning
of fandom with BBC
Radio 4 programme,
Word of Mouth.
Kings rule
their kingdoms, fans
certainly rule their fandoms.
It taps into that ancient human impulse to
belong to a group of like-minded people,
and of course, being a fan by
yourself can be a challenging thing
because fannish pursuits
can look quirky and odd...
even obsessive,
and you get often mocked and I mean,
if you're a Jane Austen fan
and you want to dress up in a bonnet
and gown of the Regency era,
it's difficult to do that
by yourself in public,
but once you join a fandom,
there's no problem.
Fans are groups of like-minded people.
They share similar opinions,
ideas or interests.
They do all kinds of weird
and wonderful things together,
such as dressing up
as Harry Potter characters - behaviour
which might be called quirky,
an adjective meaning odd or unusual,
but in an interesting way.
Unfortunately, this quirky behaviour
also means fans sometimes get mocked.
To mock somebody means to insult them
by laughing at them in an unkind way.
But this hasn't discouraged fans
who have started using new words
and phrases to show
they belong to a particular fandom.
Here's Michael Bond again,
explaining the meaning
of two new words about the behaviour
of football fans to BBC
Radio 4 programme,
Word of Mouth.
Academics who study fandoms,
they love to use acronyms
and abbreviations
and they've got several phrases which
they use to describe the behaviour
of football fans...BIRGing so that
means 'Basking in Reflected Glory'.
When your team wins
everyone wants a bit of the action,
you take to the streets, dance around...
and so the antithesis
of that is CORFing which means
'Cutting Off Reflected Failure'
and that is what people sometimes do
when their team loses
and they don't want
to be associated with
that loss, that sense of failure.
BIRGing is made of an
acronym of the words,
Basking in Reflected Glory.
It means feeling good about yourself
when the football team you support wins.
Fans say,
"WE won!",
even though it was the players
on the pitch,
not the fans,
who scored the goal.
When their team wins,
fans cheer and want a piece
of the action, an idiom meaning
that they take part in celebrations
and other exciting group activities,
and feel the success of the team
as a personal success.
The opposite of BIRGing
is CORFing, another acronym,
this time of the words,
Cutting Off Reflected Failure.
CORFING involves distancing yourself
from the team
you support when they lose.
Instead of saying, "WE won",
you say, "They played rubbish!"
Of course,
true fans never CORF.
In fact, some football fans take a
kind of strange pessimistic pleasure
when their team loses
week after week.
I can't imagine that's true
of the Americans you mentioned, Beth.
So, what was the correct answer
to your question?
I asked who the original word 'fan' was
used to describe. You said it was fans
of Disney cartoons, which was...
the wrong answer,
I'm afraid. Actually, it was
baseball fans, or 'fanatics'
as they were called at the time.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learnt,
starting with like-minded - an
adjective describing people who share
similar opinions, ideas or interests.
Quirky means odd or unusual, but
in an attractive or interesting way.
If you mock someone, you insult
and laugh at them in an unkind way.
BIRGing is short for Basking
in Reflected Glory.
It means feeling good
about yourself when the team
you support wins.
The opposite of this
is CORFing, an acronym
of Cutting Off Reflected Failure,
which means distancing yourself from
your favourite team when they lose.
And finally, if you want a piece
or a slice of the action,
you want to take part in a celebration
or other exciting group activity
to include yourself
in a collective success.
Once again,
our six minutes are up.
Join us again next time
for more trending topics and
useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute
English. Bye for now.
Bye!